[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the very first chapter
of the harry potter series the
philosopher's stone
since the philosopher's stone book was
first released in 1997
it has achieved massive commercial
success worldwide
in fact the book received so much praise
that it spawned
six more books from rowling each
expanding on the magical world
that we grew to love so much as you can
imagine
the success of the franchise didn't go
unnoticed by filmmakers
and so it wasn't long before the very
first harry potter film adaptation was
released
in 2001 however like with any film
adaptation
certain things were left out from the
books it can be hard to condense a book
into the duration
of a reasonable film length and certain
aspects just don't work on the big
screen
so this is always expected the
philosopher's stone is the shortest of
the harry potter books
at 223 pages so it has the least meat
so to speak but it's also the
introduction to the series
so filmmakers needed to ensure that the
film had a large impact
in my opinion those who worked on the
first film arguably had the hardest job
as if the film flopped then people would
have lost faith in the franchise
on the plus side at just 223 pages
the philosopher's stone had in some ways
the least ground to cover
which means that it left out fewer
elements of the book than any other film
they were able to comfortably include
nearly everything
without having the film drag on for
hours with that said
however they still missed quite a few
things now
one thing to bear in mind is that
certain aspects of the book were just
overtly omitted from the film franchise
as a whole
things like pizza poltergeist a large
number of the quidditch matches
and the clarification of the existence
of squibs
but in today's video we're going to be
discussing the philosopher's stone
specifically
what did they miss first of all they
miss an entire game of quidditch against
hufflepuff
i know i know we can't just be watching
quidditch match after quidditch match
but this match was fairly significant
because snape
refereed it acting as the referee for
the match only increased harry's
suspicion toward him
which resulted in harry wanting to end
the match quickly this added pressure
results in harry catching the snitch and
ending the match early
in fact harry ended the match in record
time next the film simplified harry and
hermione being caught out of bed
after being caught bargas filch escorts
harry hermione to mcgonagall's office
for punishment
where she decides that they will need to
serve detention that same night
both draco malfoy and neville longbottom
were also caught out of bed
which meant that they would need to
serve detention as well however
in the film neville never serves his
detention in the forbidden forest
and is instead replaced with ron this is
because the circumstances in which they
were caught
changed next centaur's bane and magorian
were completely omitted from the film
though they do sort of appear in order
of the phoenix
and instead the only centaur with any
emphasis placed on him
was forensic in the film bane chastises
forensie for helping harry
for the best what is that to do with us
zen tools are concerned with what has
been foretold
it is not our business to run around
like donkeys after stray humans in our
forest
in the book the centaurs are introduced
as a proud race of stargazers that do
not meddle with human affairs
next the film glosses over draco
challenging harry to a jewel
which occurs in chapter 9 the midnight
jewel
in this chapter draco challenges harry
to a jewel and they agree to meet at
midnight in the trophy room
when they arrive in the trophy room they
find that they were set up with draco
in an attempt to get away from filch and
mrs norris they run away
and unintentionally stumble upon the
room containing fluffy
on the third floor corridor bearing
fluffy in mind
let's segue into the next missing plot
point in the film when the trio
encounter fluffy
he's already asleep with the magical
harp playing next to him this is
slightly different in a book
they were looking straight into the eyes
of a monstrous dog a dog that filled the
whole space between
ceiling and floor it had three heads
three pairs of rolling
mad eyes three noses twitching and
quivering in their direction
three drooling mouths saliva hanging and
slippery ropes from yellowish fangs
you see in the book harry brings a flute
along with him
intending on using it to love fluffy to
sleep when they arrive
fluffy is asleep from a magical harp
which is consistent between the book
film however the primary difference here
is that the enchantment on the harp
wears off
forcing harry to play the flute
subsequently putting fluffy back to
sleep
this brings us to my next point the
challenges puzzles on the way to the
philosopher's stone
in the films though the trio still face
many challenges
a few actually omitted one was an
additional troll that was put in place
to protect the stone
and another was the potion puzzle they
stepped over the threshold and
immediately a fire sprang up behind them
in the doorway
it wasn't ordinary fire either it was
purple
at the same instant black flame shot up
in the doorway leading onwards
they were trapped brilliant this isn't
magic it's logic
a puzzle a lot of the greatest wizards
haven't got an ounce of logic
they'd be stuck in here forever now i
don't really care that they got rid of
the troll
but i would have really liked to have
seen this potion puzzle in the films
it was an obstacle that required an
immense amount of intelligence and logic
a challenge perfect for the likes of
hermione granger
danger lies before you while safety lies
behind two of us will help you whichever
you would find
one among us seven will let you move
ahead another will transport the drinker
back instead
two among our number hold only nettle
wine three of us are killers
waiting hidden in line choose unless you
wish to stay here forevermore
to help you in your choice we give you
these clues four
first however slightly the poison tries
to hide you will always find some on
nettle wines left side
second different are those who stand at
either end but if you would move onwards
neither is your friend
third as you see clearly all are
different size neither dwarfed or giant
holds death in their insides
fourth second left and the second on the
right are twins once you taste them
though different at first sight
and finally the last plot point that i'm
going to discuss pertains to the actual
events that transpired
in the mirror chamber when harry finally
reaches quirrell and obtains the
philosopher's stone
he saw his reflection pale and scared
looking at first
but a moment later the reflection smiled
at him it put its hand into its pockets
and pulled out a blood red stone
it winked and put the stone back in its
pocket and as it did so
harry felt something heavy drop into his
real pocket somehow
incredibly he'd gotten the stone in the
films harry potter kills quirrell by
grabbing his face and turning him into
dust
in the film harry blacks out after
defeating quirrell waking up in st
mungo's with dumbledore by his bedside
in the books harry blacks out while
still in a death grip with quirrell
just as dumbledore appears on the scene
when harry wakes a few things are
revealed
the first being that quirrell died the
second being pivotal information
regarding why
voldemort would want to kill harry in
the first place and
that's it for this video i hope you guys
enjoyed it moving forward i'm going to
be doing
one of these videos for each film i may
not have hit every missing aspect from
the films
but i think i covered the major ones
here if there are
any bits that i missed then comment them
down below until next time
the truth it is a beautiful and terrible
thing
and should therefore be treated with
[Music]
caution
do
[Music]
you